head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard
charts we have this tweet from the
Colorado Republican party that I saw oh
boy okay Democrats love to let criminals
crimin uh criminals loose on the street
this is what happens when you elect woke
crime Huggers to power The Simpsons
prediction certainly stands the test of
time I I am in love with this clip you
ready I'll be back you can't keep the
Democrats out of the White House forever
and when they get in I'm back on the
streets with all my criminal
buddies I love that with all my criminal
buddies can I make a point yeah it was
Trump uh who had the Jud the criminal
reform and let out a lot of people yeah
but that's not I'm just I'm just just
being but but that we like the criminal
re what we don't like is when they
arrest salon owners and then literally
unleash violent criminals into the
cities what I don't like is when people
who are like Kyle writtenhouse and the
guy in New York I don't remember his
name Daniel Penny yes who are doing the
job of the police who is ostensibly
supposed to be doing are the ones who
pay the consequence that are traumatized
for Life Luke Luke uh has has a video
about this from a decade ago where a guy
was stabbing people on the Metro in New
York City and the cops were like I'm not
getting involved and there was a court
ruling that police are not obligated to
save that's the case yeah yeah and so
this guy intervenes and gets stabbed
several times in the head and stuff and
then stops this as soon as he subdues
him then the police come in but they
were like I'm not going anywhere near
that knife what about what happened in
Britain recently with the you know the
pro Palestinian marches and the guy who
who tried to stop them who is the like a
British Patriot he got arrested of
course there's um you say of course but
I don't think it's a I don't think a lot
of people realize to what extent it's
screwed up I mean we talk about it sure
sure uh Dan dicks uh uh do you know you
know Dan no journalist he was in Canada
and there was a protest he show up to
film it they started screaming and
attacking him so the cops are threaten
to arrest him I think he might have
actually I think he got detained and
then removed it's like the innocent guy
who shows up doing nothing is attacked
and then you defend the attackers not
just innocent heroic yeah this is this
this is what I've warned about is is is
is coming when the guy in uh Wisconsin
had BLM show up to his house his private
residents protesting and he brandished a
shotgun the police showed up and
arrested him and BLM cheered for it they
don't want to abolish the police they
want the police to just arrest you mhm
yes I mean and that that's been crystal
clear from day
one definitely I mean I think one of the
issues has always been that the
marketing tactic says one thing but the
the demand is something else right they
they just want certain people to be
allowed to do things that they want they
are willing to excuse your violence or
your lawlessness if you support their
idea of who should be forgiven and once
again the first people who are going to
be the victims of violent crime are
going to be the poor yeah like it just
goes back to that again they're the most
likely to be killed raped whatever all
this other stuff and they the least
likely have access to Legal Services to
have some kind of Retribution or Justice
it's horrifying well and then they're
trapped in communities that have all of
these issues and we never find a way to
solve them because ultimately we're
funding it by saying we don't need to we
don't need to really investigate these
causes we'll just say here's money we'll
fix it also we'll let you out of jail go
back in the community we'll never
address the core issues it's just
me crazy this hand waving from
conservatives like well they shouldn't
vote a Democrat fine I'm stuck in the
projects I hate this like my life is
screwed I go and vote Republican what's
going to change everyone else around me
is voting Democrat what am I supposed to
do this system's been busted for 100
years move I guess but I can't afford
you know I'm in the projects I I don't
have poor to move yeah not everyone
who's poor is poor because of choice
that they've made but this is another
important distinction a person who has a
house is not poor relative to someone
100 or 200 years ago absolutely and so
it's interesting to see that people are
now saying like I can't move I can't
afford to move and I'm like do you live
somewhere yeah I live in government
housing I'm like they there's this great
line in fast fast and furious 4 where
the bad guy says would I follow this
line if I haven't seen the first three
yes okay he said he I'm paraphrasing but
he says if I give them things they
become dependent upon me and then they
serve me and so these people who are
like yeah I know that what's happening
in my city is wrong I know what they're
doing is evil but I can't move because
I'm stuck here and it's like that was
the plan oh yeah you are dependent on
them and now they beat you and you can't
do anything about it except for cheer
for them right there's article I read a
while ago about a study on universal
basic income and they were trying to
find women I think in Jackson
Mississippi to come be a part of this uh
Ubi test for like a year and when they
were approaching women they were like
well the thing is I don't want to lose
my benefits because once I have them
it's difficult if I lose them it's
difficult to get back on them so it's
better to maintain them for as long as I
can and that's a really interesting
system right because ultimately
theoretically any sort of Social Service
like that would be to help you for a
small amount of time to that get back on
your feet to be able to yeah and that's
not the way it works out and if it was
more of a private charity system they
would be much more Hands-On you'd have
more one-onone relationships or 1 to 10
you know maybe some kind of classes and
they would be focusing on transitioning
people from poverty into some like
there's this great um charity that penet
worked for when he was on The Apprentice
twice called Opportunity Village where
people who are like sever who are
mentally disabled it's like in Vegas
they give them jobs so like they made
Elvis's costumes like they're not going
to be able to rocket ships but they can
have some dignity and Cobalt yeah yeah
man unemployment should be you get some
little bit but then if you get a job you
get more and then that lasts for six
months and then you're only eligible
every five years to get that path or
something there should be an incentive
to get a job we could also have this off
in schools right like we could have high
schoolers who are all graduating with
the requirement that they have some
level of financial literacy that they
understand the con consequences of
credit card debt of student loans but we
don't do that right and the obvious
example with student loans is that the
government wants you to agree to take
out student loans loans which are
crippling that at 18 you may not know
the consequences of and that you are
dependent on them you are waiting for
Joe Biden to forgive them and hopefully
he will and maybe if we vote for him
again he'll finally forgive the two
loans that are ruining my life or
transition from college is this liberal
arts idea of this like 1890s creating
the next generation of Elites to have
more of a mentorship apprenticeship
program agre instead of four years at
Yale I'm spending four years at some
company and I'm starting from the bottom
and I have a mentor within the company
who teaches me the ropes I I I got an
idea abolish public schooling well I I
that's a little extreme
I I'm for it are you for it are you
kidding me that's the first thing I'd
abolished okay then so we're in
agreement number one yes public
schooling is gone uh government schools
are literal prisons for children and the
only place many people ever encounter
violence in their life you ever see the
story about the uh the kid in Chico
prisons the kid in Chicago who was
locked in a padded room and then he they
wouldn't let him go to the bathroom so
he crapped himself and was
crying the school a school in Chicago
had a padded room to lock kids in yeah I
remember I was audio where he's like
please pleas I'll be good let me out y
you could hear the kid crying some of
those are like daycare like parents that
work single parent yeah so if you
abolished it all those kids would be
homeless essentially or that's why we
have a lot of work to do no fault
divorce gone okay 19th Amendment gone
well I about that 17th Amendment for
sure that the senators are elected
that's a Nob brainer
yes I was talking to some Missouri G
public education gone all that yeah I
talking some Missouri State Rep saying
this should be the thing that you make
your bones on you should uh get rid of
no fault divorce in your state because
as soon as one state does it all the
other states will follow I think this is
something culture really wants to change
and we see that the argument like oh you
know people don't believe abuse or
whatever else like those things are so
different in the modern era and
restructuring the family and creating
social support system that begin at home
is really important there was a story
that um no since the overturning of row
no fault divorce if you take that away
you're going to be getting a lot more
rape accusations of for innocent men cuz
why wouldn't women play that card right
that's a cultural problem yes it is but
say l i I don't like I think say l when
like if you're going to I mean this is a
moral hazard that's right but who go
through women will commit crimes
therefore we should not fix the system I
I don't I I didn't say I'm just saying
if you're going to tear down a fence you
should be aware why it was put up and
what the consequences and just
anticipate them I don't think the fence
was put up because people were concerned
about false rap accusations I think the
left is trying to just destroy this
country sure but what I'm saying is
I think the this people in this country
generally are not used to the concept of
trade-offs right and just because
something is a good thing does it mean
like the idea that for example let's
suppose the vaccines were actually
prevented Co and Co was deadly but
you're probably going to get the flu for
two weeks it's a cost but it's a cost
you're willing to pay because the cost
outweighs the the bigger cost right so
but people don't think in those terms
like you can't say like this is
something you have to do even though
it's going to hurt a little bit it has
to be this something you has to do and
there's never a cost to it called
opportunity cost economics exactly I
think the issue for humans is that they
only ever want to drift towards the path
of lease resistance and so the reason
why you have wokeness today is that uh
all that is required for evil to Triumph
is that good men do nothing so when the
woke left starts causing destruction
damage pain and suffering it is easier
just to Bow your head and say Let It Go
Let It Go choose your battles and now
here we are another big problem is when
people become obsessively goal oriented
and it's like I want that goal at any
cost if the goal is to remove the fence
what How is how's that going really what
we should be doing is making a plan as
to how we're going to take that fence
down because there's a lot of ways the
fence could get removed there's a lot of
ways that the Department of Education
could disappear and one of them would be
like the United States disappearing or
like a global speaking Michael's
language so we got to be real careful
about how we're going to disassemble
this thing if we want to do it and still
maintain semblance of peace and Order
there's a book by Carol marwitz and
Bethany mandal called um stolen youth
which I just read and you know we're I
think most of
it's like you think that a lot of the
stuff that's going on in school is like
right-wing propaganda and people
frothing at the mouth but the receipts
you see and talking to parents about
what's going on in schools cuz we're not
in school so we're kind of oblivious to
it it's all everything secondhand it is
so effed up I I don't even know where to
start right and then the left lies and
say it's not happening and the media
covers for them even though it's like
here's the book here's the receipts n
information good I don't BL math is good
but like a lot of that stuff it was real
America Centric my history lessons
Columbus sailed the blue and discovered
America like I don't think you we need
to teach our kids that in the future I'm
open to like living on a farm in some
foreign country and just teaching the
kid how to farm and eat fruit and like
identify plants and like the real
important stuff thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net